joining us on the line is senator josh
halley he's the junior u.s senator from
missouri and former state attorney
general he's also the author of the
brand new book the tyranny of big tech
senator holly thanks for joining the
program i really appreciate it
thanks for having me so first of all
congratulations on the book actually
being released
obviously simon schuster had dumped the
book after january 6th for some
unspecified reason having to do with
challenging electoral results but
i'm glad that the book is actually out
there because the first amendment still
does exist technically in the united
states
yeah that's exactly right then and i'm
glad that there are still independent
publishers out there
who are willing to actually you know
publish books with diverse viewpoints
and uh i for one i said at the time when
simon and schuster tried to cancel the
book
i said you know listen part of what has
to happen for those of us who are
conservatives and libertarians is we
have to say we refuse to be canceled we
refuse to bow down to the woke mob and
now the book is in print people can read
it for themselves so let's talk today is
a perfect day to talk about the tyranny
of big tech
obviously facebook's oversight board
just upheld
the the original suspension of president
trump from facebook based on his
comments on january 6th they had
suspended him january 7th
the facebook oversight board decided
that they were right to do so but that
they couldn't do it indefinitely
because basically that's not in their
rules indefinitely they said that they
could
theoretically have just banned him or
they could have taken down the content
or they could have given a prescribed
period of time which
hilariously enough actually throws the
ball back at facebook which is
exactly what facebook wanted to avoid
that's why they created the oversight
board but this really does go to the
fact that these big tech companies don't
have
any sort of consistent standard they
apply
at all and they have enormous power to
basically get rid of anybody based on
a bootstrap justification yeah exactly
and i've said that this decision today
it really shows you it's a sad it's a
sad moment in america when free speech
depends on the whims of a corporate
monopoly which is what facebook is and
by the way
i i don't buy this distinction between
the board and facebook the board is
facebook right i mean
facebook set up the board facebook chose
its members it's funded by facebook like
let's just be honest here facebook
decided that it was okay for facebook
to suspend donald trump i mean end of
story right so all of this stuff
it's not a court you know i've seen some
of the reporting on this this morning
and they say oh
the decision is it binding is it not
what are we talking about it's not a
court
it's a fake made-up thing that facebook
designed to try it as you just alluded
to get themselves off the hot seat
when they don't follow their own rules
or when they want to do something that
their rules don't provide for so
whatever facebook needs to own this
decision
and the fact of the matter is the real
problem with facebook is they're
monopoly and they have a monopoly on
social media
increasingly a monopoly on speech and
that's the real problem here it's the
lack of competition
it's the lack of viable alternatives and
i think that's what we should be
concerned about
so you know i've for a long time been
rather libertarian when it comes to big
tech my view
uh was that that many of these companies
you could launch competitors i mean
myspace was a thing until it wasn't a
thing
um but that view has been shaken at
least
to a large extent by what happened to
parlor in the aftermath of january 6th
because
that was an attempt to build an
alternative to a place like twitter and
then
amazon web services which kind of is a
quasi monopoly in terms of the cloud
services that it provides
in the united states at least they just
de-platform parlor entirely so
it went from build your own to if you
build your own we will follow you there
and then we will destroy you
yeah exactly right that's exactly right
ben i mean it really it really
highlights the fact that we don't have
viable competitive markets in these
spaces you know the best thing would be
about what we need
is more competition we need to have
alternatives that folks can build
so that the consumers actually have real
choices but the parlor example
is just perfect here you have an actual
competitor it was still very small of
course
but it was an actual competitor starting
to get a little bit of traction and what
happens you know apple
and amazon and google snap their fingers
and literally within
48 hours it's gone it's effectively
erased
if that isn't monopoly power boy i don't
know what is
and i think it just highlights the fact
that what we need to do is we need to
break up this monopoly so that we can
have more competition now some people
say
well let's regulate the heck out of
these out of these companies
let's basically make them public
utilities let's put them under the
control of government i have to say i
i'm not a fan of that i think the thing
to do
is break up their their monopoly power
break up their monopoly status
and let's get some real competition let
the market flourish i mean
my question about that really is sort of
one of solution i do wonder if breaking
up these companies is actually going to
be successful
in allowing others to thrive in other
words is facebook really the chief
the chief obstacle to its opponents
thriving or is really the chief obstacle
to its opponents thriving
a government hand-in-glove relationship
with places
like facebook in in which the government
the democratic party has basically said
to facebook either you regulate the
first amendment or we will regulate you
i mean dianne feinstein said that quite
openly to mark zuckerberg she said
straight up
if you don't basically restrict speech
in the ways i want you to restrict
speech then we'll just
come after you and so breaking up that
monopoly
i'm not sure that that actually changes
the math on the ground as opposed to one
of the other proposals i know
that had been put forward by senate
republicans was to change
just get rid of the catch-all provision
in section 230 of the communications
decency act
uh which which i think might be an
easier way to go about it what do you
think of that
well i've actually i proposed the
changes to the to the cda as well
communications decency x section 230 and
i think we should do that then i
actually i absolutely do but i do think
that unless we
we attack their power unless we look at
their concentrated market power and
break that up
i think the danger will still remain and
you just put your finger on why that is
the democrats actually
love the concentrated power of these
companies because they can do
what government cannot do they can use
these companies to censor speech in a
way the first amendment would not permit
the government
which is why you see the democrats
saying oh they don't want to really
break them up
they just want to regulate them more
more heavily they want to make them an
arm of the state that i think is the
solution we must
it's not a solution at all that's what
we want to avoid that's a big government
big business alliance
so i think we need to do is we
absolutely need to reform section 230 we
need to give people the right
uh in my view uh to take these companies
to court when they're unfairly
discriminated against we need to restore
the good faith requirement for taking
down content that was originally in 230
but courts have basically eliminated but
we do also need to break up their power
if we don't if we don't break up their
market concentration that i think is
stifling innovation stifling competition
i promise you our friends on the left
will will not
rest until they have gotten these
companies to do the work of censorship
for them they're already doing it and
the left is just going to double down on
that
so senator holly yeah there's a lot of
talk on the left about how much they
dislike big tech and how they want to
regulate big tech obviously you're
alluding to the fact that there are some
pretty significant differences between
right and left
on how they would like to deal with big
tech the big problem on the right is
that we would like for big tech to allow
more speech and the big problem on the
left is that they would allow
they would like to to force big tech to
allow less speech
uh there seems to be sort of a
widespread um misunderstanding of that
in the american public mind they think
that right and left are united in
regulating big tech but they're calling
for almost precisely opposite
conclusions
yeah that's exactly right and that that
difference is becoming more apparent i
think as the democrats fall more and
more in love with the power of these
companies and you could see it
last fall during the hunter biden fiasco
when you had twitter
facebook again throttling down and
outright suppressing
the new york post reporting on this the
democrats love that they're cheering
that on they're saying absolutely censor
that absolutely shut that down
absolutely exercise your power
conservatives are saying whoa whoa on
what grounds are you doing this
and where can we go what other platform
can we go to
to be able to share this story and
actually have an open conversation
so you can really see if you if you look
closely you can see the left
saying more and more yeah we want to
regulate these companies regulate them
to to carry out the censorship that we
the democratic left
want and that just should be
unacceptable to conservatives not just
been for the results it reaches but
on principle because we don't believe in
a big government big business alliance
we don't believe in monopolies we
believe in the free market we think
there ought to be competition we think
there ought to be free speech
and you're exactly right what we need is
more free speech
in social media in the tech realm not
less we're speaking with senator josh
haley his new book is the tyranny
of big tech so justice clarence thomas
had suggested in a footnote in a recent
case
uh that he thinks that that maybe a
solution here would be to treat these
companies as public utilities that
essentially
they were created as open platforms at t
doesn't get to
cut off the line anytime you say
something that a t doesn't like because
they are in fact a public utility and
they are a platform they are not
an editorial content board facebook has
started to operate more like
we're going to allow what we want to
allow and what we don't want to allow
just isn't allowed
the the decision today is pretty
astonishing in a few ways uh that was
put out by the oversight board
they said for example that president
trump could be suspended because he
violated their rule quote prohibiting
praise or support of people
engaged in violent now it would be one
thing if they consistently held that
standard
but i seem to remember an entire year in
which
democratic politicians actively fomented
act of violence in america's major
cities and continue to foment the
tremendous lie that america is
systemically racist and during which
members of the media
actively compared people who were
writing and looting to members of the
boston tea party
and suggested that what they were doing
was justified so the the problem with a
lot of these these
big tech companies is is not that they
they have double standards that the
double standard really amounts to no
standard it's just a standard applied
against one side
yeah exactly right and they apply it
whatever they want to been for any
reason that they want to which is
another reason why today's quote unquote
decision
by this board is a joke i mean it
basically just says facebook just does
whatever it wants whenever it wants to
and it can do that because it's a
monopoly you know so hey i mean we just
all have to live with it
and my point is and i talk about this in
the book we don't have to live with it
we shouldn't have to live with it
these companies shouldn't have this kind
of control over our politics over speech
over our lives and there's no reason
to let them have this kind of control
now you mentioned justice thomas he's
been doing great work
in the tech space he's written a couple
of really interesting
opinions here just in the last year
talking about some of the legal problems
with this and
he does talk about common carriers uh
utilities as maybe legally something
that for courts at least
uh courts ought to be thinking about
perhaps you know he doesn't
he says he's thinking about this but
courts ought to perhaps think about
these platforms in this way
i think he's on to something there i
would say though that there's a
difference between that and congress
actually legislating to turn these
companies into public utilities
to turn them into common carriers i need
to i just have to say ben i
i'm hesitant about that you know i need
to think on that more
but i'm hesitant that that is mega
regulation
of a monopoly it's basically saying
let's accept their monopoly status and
let's just regulate the heck out of them
i kind of think that's what the
democrats would like to do i think i
think the democrats would probably say
yes
we'll we'll do that and then we'll fight
over what speech is acceptable what's
not what's equal time
what's not so that makes me a little
leery what i'd prefer to do
is just break up their concentrated
power break up the monopoly
and get some real competition in there
but listen this is a problem that
that we've got to think about a lot i
mean there's a lot to unpack and to
think on here what we cannot do
is just sit back and say well you know
we'll just hope for the best
while facebook and google and the
twitter just do whatever they want
i'm speaking of senator josh halley he's
the senator from missouri and his new
book is the tyranny of
big tech so senator holly i want to go
back to the cancellation of your book so
it was amazing the media has this
standard that
if you are cancelled by a company you've
not actually been canceled so long as an
alternative
is available which defies any sort of
logic if a company refuses to do
business with you
that company has canceled you
technically speaking and even if you can
go somewhere else that does not mean
that you were not canceled by the
original company so what exactly went
down with simon schuster what was their
excuse for canceling this book which
literally has nothing so far as i'm
aware to do with anything
january 6th related yeah it has
absolutely nothing to do with january
6th and and
in terms of why they did what they did
all i know ben is is the press statement
they put out they never contacted me
directly
they never followed up with me and this
is the company that commissioned the
book keep in mind
and i all i found out was what i read in
the press what they read in the presence
is that oh
senator hawley had a role in the
violence and the riot
at the capitol on january 6th that is
absolutely false
i had nothing to do with the riot on
january 6th i was there of course at the
time i condemned the rioters as it was
happening
it was the debate over electoral college
certification that i was participating
in that was interrupted
and i said at the time if you commit
acts of violence attack
cops uh storm federal buildings
you're criminal you gotta go to prison
and by the way that's true whether or
not you're doing it at the capitol in
washington dc or a federal building in
portland
or anywhere else for that matter the
less you know usual game is as you just
pointed out
they're fine with violence against cops
they're fine with violence
that involves federal officers they're
fine with attacks on federal property
if it's the left and if it's for leftist
causes but if they can blame it on
conservatives okay well then that's
different
my view is it's never different it's all
the same violence is wrong
political violence is illegal and if you
do it you ought to go to jail
so it was just you know simon schuster's
rationale was a total lie
they knew it was they're just bowing to
the woke mob and that's why i said i
refuse to go along with this i'm not
going to pretend that this is a
legitimate excuse
i'm going to go out and find a different
publisher and we're going to bring this
thing to the press and that's what we
did
so senator holly i would be remiss if i
didn't ask you about
the the electoral college and
challenging the the election results in
the electoral college
what was your basis for for challenging
the certification of the electoral
results the
the trump campaign really had not even
alleged sufficient voter fraud and
regularity
in something like 67 out of the 70 cases
they brought to overthrow electoral
results in in those particular states
and the the evidence of widespread voter
fraud and irregularity
there's evidence certainly of gaming the
the actual election systems in terms of
the
electoral rules like the electoral rules
in pennsylvania were a mess
but that doesn't mean that there was
actual evidence that the the election
itself
was illegitimately decided in other
words
these these votes were fully certified
right this is why the objection that i
filed was to the state of pennsylvania
and
it hinged on pennsylvania's failure to
do two things ben the first
is pennsylvania's failure follow its own
constitution the pennsylvania
constitution
does not permit universal mail-in
balloting and yet pennsylvania did it
anyway
and then when pennsylvanians filed suit
and tried to say hold on hold on
we're having mail-in balloting you know
universally our constitution doesn't
permit that
the pennsylvania supreme court which is
an elected partisan court
threw it out without even hearing the
substance of the challenge which by the
way violated their own doctrine that's
number one number two the pennsylvania
supreme court also intervened
to change the rules about when ballots
could be returned and we talked about
justice thomas a second ago justice
thomas has a great opinion
as to why that was highly irregular to
put it mildly
and a major major problem so that my
objection hinged on what happened in
pennsylvania
on these irregularities actually didn't
talk about fraud at all is you didn't
need to get there
in my view in pennsylvania these are the
kind of things the violation of their
own constitution
the the intervention of the pennsylvania
supreme court which is pretty
pretty much totally lawless those are
the kind of things i think that are
absolutely grounds for a debate about
election integrity and by the way then
that's what you get in the certification
process if you object
you get a debate you get to have an open
debate on the floor of the senate
that's why i objected along with senator
cruz and a number of other senators and
i think 140 house members
and that debate is something that the
democrats have forced
in three of the last presidential
elections every time a republican has
won they've objected to 11 states
which is you know perfect that's their
right to do that and to have the debate
it's in the rules but to say ben
that doing that following the same
procedures they followed having a debate
about election integrity pointing out
what happened in pennsylvania that
that's
akin to violence that that's inciting a
riot
that that is a big lie that's totally
false all of that's false and i think
the democrats know it's false
they just want to shut down speech they
disagree with on a federalist level are
you concerned at all that
members of congress of either party uh
challenging duly certified electoral
results because these these results were
in fact certified by the state of
pennsylvania through their normal
process
that this does federalize a system of
voting that kind of is what democrats
want i mean democrats are now pushing
for full federalization of all voting
procedure attempting to basically
vitiate the ability of states like
georgia for example to even have voter
id
or states to prevent ballot harvesting i
don't think that providing a platform
in congress for an open debate about
election integrity
or whatever the issues of the day may be
again this is a procedure this debate
procedure is one that has been used
multiple times over the years including
now i guess four times in the last 20
years so it's become a pretty familiar
procedure
and i think that's healthy ben i mean
this is why we have we we have congress
as a platform so people can be heard i
mean this is my whole point when i said
i was going to object
i said the people of my state have major
concerns
about what's happened in this last
election and pennsylvania is a great
case in point i'm going to object so
their concerns
can be heard that's why we have this
platform for debate that's why we have
congress in part so people's concerns
can be aired now
there's a big difference between having
a debate
as part of pre-existing law and changing
the law's wholesale which is what the
democrats now want to do they want to
change
all of the election laws including mine
in the state of missouri our election
laws we have voter id in the state of
missouri they want to throw that out
they want to completely federalize our
elections
and you know you could see this coming i
mean they were they've been telegraphing
that they wanted to do this they wanted
to take over our elections and that's
one of the reasons i thought we should
have a debate about this back in january
we're having it now
senator josh haley his brand new book is
the tyranny of big tech it's doing
really well on the bestseller charts
senator holly really appreciate your
time thank you so much
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment